hi everyone welcome to our daily
homeroom livestream this is our way at
Khan Academy of keeping everyone in
touch during school closures obviously
as an organization with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere we put a huge
emphasis on how do we put our materials
together to support parents and teachers
we've been running parent webinars
teacher webinars and this is a really
part of that process I do like to remind
folks we are not-for-profit if you're in
a position to do so please think about
making a donation to Khan Academy we
were running at a deficit even before
this crisis and our deficit has gotten a
little bit worse now that our costs have
gone up I do want to give a special
thanks to several corporations that have
helped us out especially through this
crisis Bank of America google.org 18t
Novartis and fastly they stepped up in
really record time and even with their
significant help we are still digging
into our reserves in order to be able to
do the work we do so once again if
you're in a position to do so please
think about donating so I am super
excited about our guest today and I see
that I'm freezing up a little bit at
least on my screen Felipe in the
background let me know if I'm freezing
up a little bit too much but my guest
today is Jim nan Dorf who is the head of
admissions at university Chicago is that
a fair way of describing you Jim and
we're talking about college admissions
and and all all all the rest so I've
been told let me close my other tabs
that might be slowing down my computer
but so maybe a good place to start
Jim is tell us how are you in and
college admissions at universe acog oh
but I'm assuming it's indicative of a
lot of other places how are you thinking
about the kovat crisis and next year's
admissions oh well we think about it in
a lot of ways obviously the university
as a whole is making plans for what we
can do on campus and what we will do
online currently our students are online
as almost every school that I can think
of is doing and in terms of the
admissions efforts we
are kind of doubling down and making
sure that all the things that a student
needs to do to learn about our school to
learn about how to apply to highly
selective schools to write good essays
to to showcase their academic promise
that all of that is being communicated
to them in a whole host of ways we have
opened up so many different online tours
info sessions Spanish information
sessions we've got alumni doing work
we've got tour guide panels and all of
this is not just about the University of
Chicago it's really to help all the
students understand you know what do you
need to do over the next six to seven
months to be prepared to apply to any
school and and in in some odd way there
you can actually do more and be better
prepared to put a great application
together through all the resources that
you spotlight all my peers are putting
together for for our students so I mean
this is not the time to panic this is
actually the time to focus on the things
you can do not what you can't do and I
want to remind all the viewers whether
you're on YouTube or Facebook put your
questions in we have team members we're
monitoring this is your chance to ask
Jim really anything and I'm happy to
answer any questions that you might have
as well but Jim may be a good place you
know as you mentioned this isn't the
time to panic everything's gonna be fine
but you know we've had previous sessions
where we talked about the SAT and AP
tests and kids were worried about some
tests getting cancelled or they're
different this year how are y'all
thinking about the tests optionality of
things or these new types of tests sure
so testing and the fact that like
students have gone our online doing
their you know their own high school
work and some of their grading has gone
from you know letter grades to pass/fail
all of this is happening and I want to
assure all the families that admissions
officers did not have their heads stuck
in the sand or stuck up other places
which I've been told I do on occasion
you know that we actually know what's
going on in the world and we are trying
to accommodate those things so I'll
start I guess with the testing so many
students have taken tests for those
students that haven't taken tests there
will be testing available in the fall
there's also you Chicago Mo's test
optional so we have we don't require a
testing you can submit your testing if
you've already taken it you're good at
it or you could print out some of the
work you've done on Khan and send that
in and said you know and tell us Oh life
you know I've achieved mastery of this
there's all kinds of tests APs
SAT twos a CT all of this if you've done
it and you want to submit it great many
schools are going to be test optional
this year so some of the flagship state
publics many of my peers and there's
over a thousand schools that were
already test optional service schools
that are still going to require testing
I guarantee there will be testing
opportunities in the fall either live
in-person you know the way it had been I
know the SAT the College Board is adding
test sittings and so every month I
believe beginning in August there will
be a testing and then if no one is
allowed to you know if through the virus
gets worse and we're all back home and
and unable to - to go to a test center
and take tests with other people the the
SAT will be online they have guaranteed
that they will offer an online version
so whether you are applying to schools
that require testing or do not require
testing everything will be fine just
continue to study hard work hard and do
the things you can do everything will be
you there's no need to worry about it I
guess is the best way to say it and
we're getting a ton of questions and I
actually want to get to these questions
but you know you mentioned test optional
and I think test optional has always
been a little bit confusing for some
students what what's your read of test
optional you know it doesn't mean if you
do well on the SAT or a CT that's great
what if you didn't do well how do you
are you at a disadvantage somehow you
definitely are not at a disadvantage
applying without testing to test
optional schools so the way I think of
test
it's one way of showcasing your academic
promise some students instead of
submitting testing they submit amazing
artwork or music they say I have
students who have gotten they they have
built business plans they have patents
already they they run companies I have
students who just get a little nervous
about taking testing you have students
who have not had access to test prep you
have students who you know the worst of
all sins they did not know about Khan
Academy and so these students testing
didn't showcase their very best the
testing does not showcase who they are
and so send me something else in lieu of
that a paper that you're really proud of
there's no reason to feel and every
school will tell you this testing is not
the be-all end-all it can be an
important part of your application but
it doesn't have to be no that's that's
super super helpful and I mean just
going with that theme from YouTube Ben
QB asks will you guys look at AP tests
from this year cuz AP test is clearly a
little bit different how are y'all
thinking about that we will so so we
never required the AP tests in the past
and we will look at them essentially the
same way we've looked at them if
students who have taken the AP and
decided to take the AP online tests will
treat them as valid just as we did any
other testing we we have crediting
policies for students who were admitted
and come and so so we no change in how
we will view the APS and I think that
will be the case for most of for most of
my peers this is here again if a student
is nervous about taking their testing
online I'm sure we will understand ok
some students just won't take the AP
test this year because they were nervous
about doing it online and we will
understand that and and be accommodating
through that and I hope she want to
double click on that because there is
this perception especially with students
who might want to go to a place like
University of Chicago they have these
archetypes in their mind you know the
kid who gets a 5 on 5 AP tests and then
she's the
you know gets a 1500 on their SAT and
they do XY and Z but some of what you
just said it isn't that you're saying
there's other ways but I think there's
might be people who are skeptical
they're like well he's just saying that
because he wants my application
convinced us no all right sure well I
will all right so I'll start with so I
places like Chicago I used to work for
Yale you know I go to all these meetings
with the other Ivy Dean's you know at at
Chicago I get about 300 kids with
perfect SATs apply every year and we
reject 60% of them now that's supposed
to make you feel good if you're online
don't freak out this is supposed to make
you feel good it basically says that the
testing is only one piece of holistic
review and we care about your grades and
your activities and your essays in fact
the vast majority of my applicants are
more than qualified I have about 35,000
applicants
30,000 of them would do really well at
use Chicago and when you get down to the
last 10,000 essentially there they
academically they're identical everybody
is getting good grades good testing tip
things together and when you get down to
the last 5,000 you know essentially I
could kill everyone in the freshman
class and replace them with the wait
list and nobody would never do a
beautiful already of the applicants is
great and that's not what differentiates
you that's not what makes you use
Chicago student what makes you you
Chicago student or what you put into the
essays and how you respond and the kind
of person you are and in love of
learning and if that comes through in
the application then we admit you I know
you're one of the nicest of people I
know so yeah Jim does not do any killing
one thing I mean you just touched on
that you know put in your essays that
that authenticity that's something we
talk a lot about I love your insider's
point of view of how you spot authentic
versus inauthentic applications sure so
one of the things you'll hear from
almost any of the highly selective
Dean's is that everything kind of holds
together yeah so the students voice that
you hear in their first essay which is
about kind of who they are
you know with their background what they
believe in that that voice will then
carry on in their second essay which is
typically unique to each school so we
have our zany UChicago prompts and the
voice and the kind of person you're
meeting there will be in the second
essay they'll be in the third one which
is you know why do you want to go to my
school why are you that fit for you
Chicago and then if the voice is
consistent across all of those and the
kind of kid you're hearing the teacher
recommendations will reinforce that same
thing and so you can really tell when
somebody else has been involved and so
if I had one strong piece of advice for
all the families listening and students
listening it's don't let adults get
involved in writing your essays we can
smell them a mile away they should say
you should sound like a 17 year old not
a 41 year old lawyer and so you know all
that all the work the whole application
should should kind of tell the same
story and a story of the kind of kid you
want on your campus did that that's
super helpful if you want to share at
any point I'd love to hear stories of
applications that you work that were
clearly written by the 41 year old
lawyer oh my god you know I had this one
that I really just you know so I have
one where it was it was like from
another school there Dean and I were
talking it was like I was on their
campus and the only thing buzzing more
than the bees was me at all the academic
opportunities I was like no 17 year old
would would would ever write like that
but on the flip side I have I mean I
will never forget this one wonderful
essay that I read from a girl that I
referred to as the cannibal essay where
she was at an all-girls Catholic school
in California and our essay prompt that
year was cats and dogs montagues and
capulets autobots and decepticons there
are two kinds of people in this world
what are they and she wrote about how if
there was an earthquake and they were
all trapped how she would divide the
student body into those students she
would eat and the students she would not
eat and it was hysterical and funny and
something clearly only a 17 year old
would write and the last part was you
know and so it's not whether the
juicy and succulent its whether they're
interesting and that's why I would eat
them and that's why I want to go to use
Chicago to be around interesting people
and eat them like yes and it should be
admitted her and I checked the roommates
and they're always alive so everything's
fine yeah this is you know it's
memorable
it speaks to who they are no this has
got a little bit morbid on some of these
points I think your your your point is
exactly right that you know these things
that are quirky that aren't a template
that show clear creativity definitely
stand out clearly for you that I mean
did do we make the Jim Donnan doors of
the world smile and remember that seems
like a pretty good indicator so a lot
more questions here from YouTube Adithya
Gupta asked how is the inability to
compete in sports change in standardized
testing along with change in access to
extracurricular activities affecting the
admissions process oh that is a great
that's a great question because well it
falls into two categories so first
there's like the athletes who thought
are hoping to be recruited and you
should not worry because the coaches
I've you're going to be submitting
testing I mean that videos some coaches
may reach out to you and ask you to
video yourself doing certain activities
whether it's how fast you run or agility
drills and things like that
the the varsity coaches will lead you
along the way and the process for
getting that started is pretty much the
same for everybody you go online to the
schools you're interested in you go to
the websites of the athletic department
the specific team that you're interested
and they will there's a forum for you to
fill out that says you know I'm
interested and they ask you all the the
details you know I can benchpress this
much run this fast whatever the case
might be so outside of being a recruited
athlete what you do it whatever you were
doing we will take it that you know we
kind of look at it and say well they
probably would have done that this this
last spring and it whether you were an
athlete or a singer or you do community
service you take care of an LD elderly
relative you work there's nothing wrong
with working whether you were a thespian
it doesn't that
what you specifically do doesn't matter
it what matters is that you're
passionate about something that you were
engaged in it that you liked it that you
learn from it that you learn teamwork
and that can be done in many ways and
the fact that you had one season off is
not going to make an impact at all
please do not worry about that
every every time I give talks just
giving one right before the the stay at
home orders with what's to smell he was
a wonderful guy and one of my best
friends at MIT and he was saying how you
know that we talked about this and we
say there is no like set of things that
everybody has to check to get in you
know if you didn't do community service
for like ooh they must be like you know
killing baby seals at night you know we
don't think that it's not what you don't
do it's what you do you know that that
we're interested in and so really try to
try not to worry about the what's your
missing just engage in something else
no Jim your infectious you make me want
to apply to college I know
so so we're getting a whole series of
questions here that are dealing with
kovat from Facebook Aditi dagger what do
you do you think that trends for the
class of 21 will continue for future
classes what changes you see for 22
onwards from Facebook Carolyn consort
can asks if many of the classes each
high school class of twenty kids take a
gap year
how will this affect admissions I guess
for waitlist this year and for next
year's class well there are a lot of
things there so why don't I I'll give
you some of the you know we're in
uncharted territory to be very honest
who knows what who knows what's going to
happen I'll give you what up the things
that I am expecting so right now we
don't have any more kids asking for to
take a gap year than we've ever had they
always have about you know 15 20 this
time of year and that's and they're
doing really cool and exciting things
that I want them to do it in terms of
how what things are going to take place
so here's here's my theory on this and
I'd love to hear your thoughts on itself
so you know maybe it's 15 20 years ago
all of a sudden everyone realized it's a
global world and we should have study
abroad program so you know maybe it was
longer ago but but really everybody at
you know jumped on to study abroad
because you needed to know that there
are other cultures and engage them and
it was a it has become an important part
of every school's academic kind of
program and we are learning a lot about
what is useful in online teaching and I
could imagine over the years ahead
that there would be a reason to have
online virtual classes even during your
four years with no other external pushes
but because when you graduate you are
going to need to know how to do these
things how to be self-directed how to
how to sit and listen to a video for you
know 45 minutes and pull out the
important things it's what you're going
to do if you work for Goldman Sachs it's
what you're going to do if you become a
teacher a lawyer it doesn't matter and
so I think the the skills that that that
students will need in the future that
online education could be a part of that
just like study abroad is I don't think
it's gonna be all online and I wouldn't
I think you get enormous value in our
residential four-year model but I do
think that there's always something you
can learn in every crisis you know in
every crisis and every war something
comes up you know we wouldn't have had
Telus penicillin if there weren't a war
you know it's it's these are
opportunities challenges create
opportunities I know I could say for my
own area so college admissions that we
are going to continue offering virtual
activities online activities the ability
for students to we're creating a jukebox
essentially a jukebox of all of the
videos of classes that we have and there
will be more opportunities for students
because of this crisis than there were
in the past and it will be more
available to students of all
socioeconomic backgrounds you know it is
great that a student can actually get
more information about Chicago today
than they could have in the past
and all of it is free that only only
basically have to go online as opposed
to a hotel room a flight to Chicago you
know and those things so there's a lot
of benefit that's going to come out of
this it's hard to see that now but I
really do believe that and related to
that I know you know your focuses on
admissions but I'm sure you're part of
the broader conversation at the
university how is the university
thinking about contingency planning for
this back to school or if the virus
picks back up
sure so um every school is thinking
about this I can tell you that one of
the the huge values we have at Chicago
is that we also are part of a
multi-billion dollar hospital they use
Chicago Medical Center and we working
with the epidemiologists we are learning
a lot about how do you how do you
operate in in the midst of the epidemic
how do you make sure that doctors don't
get sick how do you make sure nurses
don't get sick all of the important
aspects of social distancing and using
what kind of masks and things like that
and we're going and we're looking at how
do we take that expertise and that
learning and leverage it into the fall
so our first and highest goal will be to
make sure that our students are safe and
that they're back on campus learning the
way we would want them to you know
obviously you have multiple contingency
plans where maybe everybody doesn't come
back or you know if things go terrible
in the fall I'm sure you know governor's
about many states will tell their
universities they can't open but we are
we are going to do everything we can to
be open and to be teaching and engaging
our students because we don't want that
output is important it's important for
their education it's important for the
country and and quite honestly this is
what the university is all about I feel
we're very well prepared for it
thankfully because we have a great
hospital right next door to us at a lot
of places they don't have those experts
they don't have hospitals you know
essentially on their campus even places
that have wonderful hospitals they're
not attached you know they're in a
different part of the city they are on
the other side and they're not even in
the same city at Chicago the Medical
Center is essentially the next quad over
from the main
quad and so we are committed to engaging
our students we're going to do a lot of
virtual things online with them this
summer I'm going to do a lot of virtual
things online as prospects this summer
and my hope is that we will have tours
and our students will be back in the
fall no that's that's great and
obviously none of us really knows what's
gonna happen but it sounds like y'all
have a good good handle on it it's
another question about test option on
I'll extend a little bit you too from
YouTube golden bucket asks where is the
list that has own actually there's a
different one oh this is from Amy S
Morgan see that's the question I wanted
to ask from Facebook Jim what has been
your experience going test optional do
you ever miss the SAT a CT is a tool and
I'll extend it a little bit because not
only are the test optional a lot of
school districts I know went to
pass/fail this past term who knows what
happens so there's this general trend
that at least on this these academic
numerical objective measures you might
have less data than you typically have
is that true especially with test
optional and how do you navigate that
sure so so I guess I'd start with you
need to have some kind of valid
information that comes in and the
transcript is is great for that testing
is great for that what I think tests
actual schools do is we we offer other
opportunities so there are other ways
that other things that students can send
in in terms of what do I do I miss it
well to be honest not eighty five ninety
percent of my application in testing
because they think testing is is a good
representation of their academic quality
that's great in terms of their worries
about what out what else could they send
in it I think a good applicant and a
good application and a good college
search all starts with all start with
the same thing which is let me think
about myself what makes me unique what
makes me special what makes me a good
fit for schools then you go and you
visit schools and you learn about what
makes them unique and eventually I'm a
big believer you'll get a vibe and you
can get that vibe even electronically
and you'll get a sense this is the right
school for me and then you look at what
they're looking for and you try to
showcase those attributes
in your application I want to get really
specific about this on the testing piece
so students I sometimes see students
take the test you know three five seven
nine times and I am like that's one you
look neurotic and - you should write it
down as a extracurricular activity
you've taken it so many times
testing is not to be taken that many do
you take it a couple of times and that's
what your score is and then and you can
submit it if you'd like - the reason I
say that is because within a hundred
points it just doesn't matter in the
admissions committee room you know I see
students a student who's taken the test
got a 1580 and then they take it four
more times when it's a waste of time and
it doesn't reflect positively on them as
a person and so it really is the same
thing with GPAs like the most worthless
piece of information I get is the GPA
because I get it in every conceivable
format 4.0 5.0 6.0 ten-point Oh 12-point
a weighted unweighted that sounds
quintiles quartiles sometimes they just
give you smiley faces at schools and we
still don't have to figure out a way to
look at that applicant and say how did
you do what did you take you know have
you prepared yourself and in general
most of my applicants have done very
well on you know on their academic
pieces what's going to make them stand
out in a in an applicant pool like we
have and like my very highly selective
peers have is what makes their the rest
of their application compelling and that
quite honestly comes through teacher
recommendations the extracurriculars
they do and in many ways their essays
these essays tell us so much about their
dreams and the kinds of students they
are and the kind of learners they are
and what kind of an impact they're going
to make on our campus and on the world
and you know we talked about the the
kids who do submit the test there's that
as you mentioned 10 to 15% who for
whatever reasons might not want how do
you do that and how are they able to
show at least on the academic side that
they they can they can go you know they
can be in the same academic environment
as that you know the students who are
scoring very well on these tests sure
so some of them will actually take spend
a lot of time on Khan Academy and they
can and I can see that they have
acquired the skills that's another
excellent way to validate your grades in
high school is by doing doing work on
Khan Academy that's like an eat not an
easy one but one that shows me two
things one mastery but even more
important it shows me work ethic you
know persistence you know of the kids
who are not naturally good at math but
keep plugging away at it that's a great
skill to have so that's one set that I
would also see there's another set of
students for whom both the full test
score is not as relevant to what they're
planning to do when they get to use
Chicago or many schools great example
art history I can have an applicant who
puts together this amazing art history
application and they've done all of this
work and they write these amazing essays
and and and you can see they are going
to get a PhD in art history and probably
you know change the field and the fact
that they have a 600 maybe on their math
SAT section it doesn't matter you know
to me I don't feel like I don't need to
know and it tells me that what does to
what I need to know is can they do the
match requirement at U Chicago I can
look at their transcript and it says
they have a B+ in AP Calculus sold you
were going to be a great you Chicago art
historian that's super useful and I
guess related to that from Facebook have
this question from Mayor room Hammoud
who asks how to guide our kids to the
most suitable College or path in their
higher education and I'll just add to
that you know there there tends to
sometimes be an obsession with the use
Chicago's of the world the highly
selective universities it causes anxiety
people try to you know their whole ego
their identity is defined by where they
go to school what advice do you have for
folks now so I'll start with there is no
be-all end-all school other than the
University of Chicago of course and and
and in many ways please do not equate
your sense of self-worth your value your
accomplishments to getting into any
highly selective school if that's not
how it works
this is not
our processes that about evaluating
students and saying this student is good
and this student is bad this is an
economics problem sent I have a limited
number of spaces for students and I have
many many more wonderful amazing
students
that I would love to take that I can
actually take and have on campus
admissions I want you to know that
admissions officers become very attached
to their applicants sometimes you know
people cry in admissions committee
something at me but sometimes they cry
because they've become so attached to
these students and so that's the first
thing is don't this process is not about
placing a value on you as a person or on
your accomplishments the second piece of
that is how do you go about thinking
where do I where am i a good fit and you
are in great this is you're in a great
position right now because every school
is putting together a lot of ways for
you to do that from your home if it were
me I would start at a high level and say
okay I'm going to look at three large
private research universities websites
and videos and tours and attend a class
online and then I'm going to do that for
three liberal arts colleges and I'm
gonna do it for three large public
schools and I'm gonna get a sense of
what the vibe which ones I liked what
what resonated with me and after you do
that then you can go and look deeper
into that category so let's say you you
looked at you Chicago into much less
positive and totally inferior schools
like Harvard and Princeton and then you
visit the three of our schools and and
you say wow I really like research
universities well then you can look at
other fine institutions like Stanford
and Yale and everybody else but it's
it's getting a sense of what's a good
fit for you at the beginning and then
once you've done that that's when you
start the process of saying what makes
why why would they want me why am i a
good fit for them and it takes a little
Suffolk evaluation and examination and
and then you choose a a nice balanced a
College list which has some schools that
are highly selective and some that are
selective and some
are less selective than that and some
schools where you think you're an
excellent fit and you apply to them and
I can tell you that in general everybody
advice pretty much goes to college you
know they if you do these things you
will have options and that's what this
process a bit Pacis will leave you with
options and a super super valuable have
this question from YouTube
Aditya Gupta asks Jim what happens if
you come from a disadvantaged school
with limited resources compared to more
schools and in affluent communities how
do you stand out with limited resources
awesome so there are many ways to do it
and they're all the same ways that the
one resource to students can do anybody
can write a great essay anybody can
engage locally in their community what
anybody can hopefully if you don't have
internet access at home eventually a
libraries will open and you can go to
the library your local library and learn
a little bit about these schools many
schools so we have a whole set of
programs for first-generation students
we have our Odyssey program which is
essentially for families of Llosa who
have less financial means we have
fly-ins we do programming for these
students in with their community-based
organizations we partner up with
programs like West bridge or Jack Kent
Cooke foundation and you know these
programs where we essentially if your
school wants my admissions officer to
come and give a talk to your into you
alone or all of your classmates we have
those options available and so they're
really we are committed and I'm we're
not the only school my peers are equally
committed to doing this and then we set
aside hundreds of millions of dollars to
ensure that you can come to the
University of Chicago so and or Yale or
Harvard or Stanford you know we have you
know there are no loan school so you can
you can decide to come and there's no
loans and your packages you graduate
without debt you know the the average
that the students who are like on PAL
essentially everything is covered if
your family makes less than $60,000 it's
free to go to use
and some of my peers have similar
programs like that and so I would I
would say to you don't let your current
situation so I was the first gen low
income student from Hammond Indiana and
I went off to Yale and that it was
because you know I you make the most of
what you're given and quite honestly
that stands out what you do with the
resources you have it is what is what
will make an impact in your application
EE want to triple e want to underline
what you just said because I think we
probably had very similar childhoods you
know growing up I you know MIT was
always the school that I I didn't even
know much about but somehow I wanted to
go there but I loosed a look at the MSRP
tuition and it's like my mother made
sixteen thousand a year she was a
cashier at a convenience store I was on
free lunch I was like week I'm not gonna
be able to go there and it was my sister
who told me about financial aid and so
to your point if you're you know below
sixty thousand not not not even where my
mom was but if you're if you're if your
family does make a lot you can you can
leave your Chicago with without it
sounds like note with no debt which is
better than the deal I had back in the
90s oh yeah financially it is it
improved alot since you and I were in
college I have to tell you and how does
the co fit crisis changing thing I mean
we're seeing record unemployment there's
going to be a lot more folks in that
category unfortunately I'm guessing the
endowments are down because of the stock
market or is that going to change
financial aid what's been wonderful is
that the the at the top schools you know
there has been a constant reactivation
certainly there has been at the
University of Chicago that our main part
that the financial aid and supporting
our low-income students remains a we are
committed to that and that is not in
changing regardless of how things are
going in the you know in the economy and
alumni and our board have stepped up
there have been major campaigns
especially in the last year giving to
our Odyssey scholarships which is the
financial aid for low-income students
millions of dollars have actually been
raised since the current you know Sims
like March to assist our own low-income
students
and that current students in
transitioning back to their homes
setting them up with computers Wi-Fi you
paying for their their trips home you
know that has been a major commitment
and I don't see the very very top
schools changing that thankfully the
government is also now kicking in some
additional funding for that through the
cares Act I would imagine there will be
more of that if the if the crisis
continues or worsens but the bottom line
is this is a fundamental piece of who a
place like Chicago is and some of our
other highly selective peers which is we
are here to bring bring the very best
and brightest
we're godless of socio-economic
background regardless of cultural
background regardless of political views
and academic views you know we want the
best and brightest and you only get that
if you're willing to put your put your
finances behind that commitment that's
super valuable and we're getting a ton
of questions unfortunately we're running
out of time Jim I would love to have you
on again I mean your energy is
infectious and I think there's clearly
people are engaged maybe it's just a
good end question you know Pierce
Schumann on from YouTube says and what
is the most impressive thing that you
can see on someone's application and
I'll just extend it what advice do you
have someone's applying that you to
Chicago they want to be noticed by Jim
nan Dorf what advice what should they do
in their life and what should they do on
their application ah so the first and
the most important thing is don't ask
what I think you should be doing you
should you should think about who you
are and be true to yourself the best
applications are authentic and really it
it's like this is who I am
and I like Who I am and you're gonna
like Who I am and I'm going to show it
to you in your application those are the
applications you remember and that stand
out the ones that you know where a
student is like oh I'll bet they'll want
to hear this or oh I should go do this
activity because it'll look good on my
application that's not the way to go
about this process it is be who you are
be proud of who you are put your best
foot forward and it does work out
well Jim thank you so much and I love
you know every time I talk to you I
think you represent authenticity you
represent you know my advice to the
students out there is be like Jim NAND
or don't be exactly like him but he is
himself he's not trying to filter out he
has no talking points I've talked to
admissions officers that are just
reading talking points out that you know
that a committee has put together and
that's not you and I think the same
thing is true for students if you have a
committee giving you talking points
she's probably not a good attentive okay
so so be yourself and I got to say my
own application in college I didn't know
what a good application looked like so I
I drew a picture and I wrote this crazy
dream that I had and and and people
thought I was crazy to submit that but
it got me in yeah well sure I can't say
thank you enough for all you do I mean
you're a great friend and I love
spending time with you and really what
you do and how you were changing lives
through Khan Academy is amazing so I
hope you hear that every day because I
think about it every day so really thank
you know Jim and I gotta thank you the
the love is mutual and you know for
those who don't know you know Jim and I
were always brainstorming ways that Khan
Academy can be even more helpful for
folks to get in college applications and
you know Jim and I were just
brainstorming are there ways that
students could take screenshots and show
it to the college admissions of the
world and it sounds like it could be
really valuable so we're excited about
exploring stuff like that okay take care
thanks so much thanks everyone so thanks
for attending today's daily live stream
I'll remind is teacher appreciation week
so I want to make sure I do get that
call out that huge appreciation to all
the teachers and I'd say even admissions
officers in my life and and other
people's lives but I hope y'all get a
lot of it I hope we can bring Jim on
again because I think there's a lot of
questions that we didn't get to but I
want everyone to stay safe stay healthy
and we will see you tomorrow on the live
stream
you